10% of all residents have died there was
conflicting information at the start of
this epidemic
they should have be sent back to care
homes without testing should they not we
saw what happened and we've also heard
from Matt Hancock he said that care
homes yesterday care homes the
responsibility of local government what
do you say to those who suggest that you
are washing your hands of those who need
us the most
well I would be appalled if people
thought that I think it's the
responsibility of government to work as
hard as possible to improve the
situation and indeed to make it very
clear that when things aren't going as
well as they should we need to do better
and on care homes I think that is very
clear I mean I've looked again at what
happened back in February and March and
once now it's not the time to go through
the tea leaves and work out just see
what had happened then I think it's
clear that care homes themselves were
taking measures to stop visitors coming
in I think the admissions back from
hospital are a very important point and
when the evidence that I'm seeing the
rate of admission back from hospital
actually was declining from its January
height and that only 5% of those being
admitted to care homes were new
admissions that clearly you know is an
important factor here when considering
the overall impact upon our care house
but you know I listen to people I listen
to local providers as well and clearly
there were huge issues and we've seen a
great tragedy in our care homes which is
a matter of huge regret but I'm glad to
note that in the last two weeks we've
now started to see a decline in the rate
which is encouraging but there's more to
do nevertheless forty percent forty
percent of all deaths are in care homes
what mistakes did you make
well I think we rightly emphasized the
importance of making sure that our NHS
services and our hospitals were places
that could continue to admit patients
and wouldn't be incubators of the
disease we achieved that we protected
our NHS we ramped up our capability
which meant that it didn't thankfully
fall over at a time of huge pressure and
tribute has got to be paid to everybody
who made that effort and also in what
we've done with testing there are
welcome to testing if we may and still
our own care homes at the moment and
then we'll rattles through so you're
saying that you focused in your opinion
quite rightly on the National Health
Service at the death to the detriment of
care homes well I think we need to make
it we needed to make a choice about
testing and we did decide to focus upon
the NHS I think the issue with care
homes is that we've got many thousands
of different providers different
settings there been lots of examples of
care homes that have mercifully stayed
infection free but sadly far too many
cases of infection and then death I
think that every country in the world
will look back and say there are things
we could have done differently okay on
the National Health Service I'm not
saying it's right or wrong I'm asking
what the policy was it was to focus on
the National Health Service first and
foremost well that's right and I think
that was absolutely essential you know
now is not the time to to blame people I
think that would be wholly
counterproductive we've got to work
together not just with a care home
sector but with our scientists with all
the people who advise governments
together come to sensible solutions okay
so that was the decision that was made
40 percent of people who've died are in
care homes as a result as we suppose we
said yesterday the judicial inquiry will
no doubt be looking at that in a detail
another group twice as vulnerable as the
average are diabetics given that we've
learned what we've learned from what
happened with care homes what are we
doing to wrap cotton wall around people
who are twice as vulnerable like
diabetics
well okay I think one of the important
points you've just Illustrated there is
our evolving knowledge about the nature
of this disease so you've seen the
change in the recognize symptoms list we
announced this week and we're seeing
more and more learning about how it can
affect people who have perhaps obese
certain types of person about certain
ethnicities who are more vulnerable
we're learning all the time about this
disease you know the knowledge that we
had back in March when we were making
the decisions we've talked about care
homes wasn't as developed as the
knowledge we have now and of course that
knowledge will continue to develop so I
think it's important that we focus upon
groups we are absolutely unafraid to
identify new vulnerabilities and then to
take action and as the science emerges
on diabetes on obesity then we will take
the appropriate steps to protect people
there are the groups within that that we
should also be looking at diabetics OB
clinically obese Bahm of course any
other groups okay look I'm not going to
stand here and say you've got a
definitive list they may well be
emerging science about other types of
vulnerability that we need to address
very quickly but you know like all
countries in the world we are still
learning about this virus and that means
that this isn't this isn't a fixed sort
of set of facts or circumstances this is
an evolving position and the
government's had to devolve and change
and develop its policy in accordance
with that which is why it is very
difficult now in late May to make
definitive judgments about decisions
made in March the position and our
knowledge was very different then to
what it is now a note o our knowledge
will be even more developed come June
and July um you become a bit of a
hostage to fortune the government on
setting dates that you then can't reach
is the 1st of June for getting schools
back another one of those because it
certainly looks increasingly as though
it is well I think we were right to set
dates we were being criticized because
we weren't doing that you know people
said well what's the road back you know
we haven't a clue about how to plan and
I think it was right that we said that
date we always said that the 1st of June
was conditional not just on the r8 but
on the need to make places of work
safe I'm hearing what's being said by a
range of different employers and
representatives of our brilliant
teachers who but already are working
with key workers families and vulnerable
children to provide education services
let's not forget that and I think as as
the picture emerges we've seen the vmas
really helpful advice this morning you
know bit by bit I think we're seeing a
position emerging where if it is safe
and if people feel safe to be able to
work in those environments then that can
happen from June but I accept the
pictures of mixed one at the moment the
conversations continue I know my
colleague the Secretary of State for
Education is talking and working
actively with representative groups
we've got to keep that going and
hopefully by the 1st of June we will see
a range of different establishments
opening for those vital year groups that
need education and need it now but you
acknowledge that it might given what
we've seen with the pushback from the
teaching unions and also local councils
it might not be as many as you had
previously hoped but we've got to accept
the fact that you know some of the
council's of course our employers
decisions have to be made collectively
there will be other institutions that
feel it is safe to open up and we should
respect that as well I think you know
this is a developing picture 10 days to
go it's not a long time I accept but I'm
encouraged by the conversations that I'm
hearing only this morning I had a
contact from a nursery provider who
feels that they are ready and at work
with staff in order to provide a safe
setting and in fact I have been caring
for very young children throughout this
crisis so there will be plenty of
examples where people feel they're able
to do that but I have actually respect
the views of those who want to exercise
greater caution which is why we've got
to keep the dialogue going ok given that
you say that the government should step
date set targets where are we on contact
tracing programs when might we see those
fully operational
I think the aim had been to get those
programs going by the end of the month
and we've already seen you know a big
recruitment drive on we've now got I
think 21,000 volunteers to do the
contact trace program this will
Mick's program it'll involve individual
tracers actually working with the
community and then of course we're
piloting that app in the Isle of Wight
that still work-in-progress
I think the aim is K to get things
moving as quickly as possible I'm
confident that with the recruitments
that we've made we can get on with that
over the next few weeks and then see
that particular program increase in its
size emergency which will help us hugely
but just as Secretary you said that you
like dates they are targets that we
should aim towards what days are we
looking at for the contact tracing
program to be fully operational well I
think the plan have been to get things
moving by the end of the month I think
it will be a developing picture I think
we will see it gradually increase in its
potency and range particularly with the
introduction of any electronic digital
mechanisms as well but from what I'm
seeing the progress is really
encouraging we can't let up on this this
is urgent and important work and from
everything that I've seen I'm confident
that we will get this up and running
very very soon okay so let's say by the
middle of June contact tracing all being
well will be fully functional here in
the United Kingdom well that the aim is
of course to do it as soon as possible
and genius begin assembly wait I'm
saying in a month time will it be fully
operating okay I don't know fully the
picture with regard to the development
of the pilot what I do know is that I
think we'll see a position which will
quickly enlarge and improve over the
next few weeks and I very much hope that
June will be the time that we see that
key change and that spread of this
system this mechanism throughout our
community so how disappointed will you
be if it's not fully operational by the
middle of June say well I think I'll be
frustrated and disappointed if we don't
make the progress that we want to make
over the next few weeks it's been a you
know a time when I've been surprised and
pleased by the developments that we made
I think you might remember I was a
little bit pessimistic about whether
we'd make that hundred thousand testing
target by the end of May but I was
proved wrong I'm glad that I was proved
wrong and I'm sure that I'll be proved
wrong again on many occasions throughout
this fast-developing
crisis and I don't have the powers of
clairvoyance that some people would like
me to have because you said date so I
was just you know challenge you on the
dates because you said that they were
important that's why I was asking you
for dates for contact tracing I know you
have to go so two very quick questions
before I let you go
the slogan it first of all it will stay
at home then it was stay alert now we've
changed it again to keep our distance
wash our hands think of others play our
part did we not like the stay alert one
stay alert still very much part of what
it's all about I think what we're trying
to do is explain underneath that general
direction what that means and of course
the different elements of staying alert
which include washing hands keeping our
distance build up to that general
approach which is that we all must be
very much aware not only of each other
but what we can do in order to minimize
the inadvertent transmission of this
terrible disease yes Taylor it didn't
work quite as well though did it a stay
at home well I sing stay at home had the
you know the the the clarity and
simplicity of a direct sort of
instruction this was always going to be
a more difficult moment when we had to
give more nuanced messages and to
encourage everybody to take those small
steps out to the full lock locked out
gonna be a tough fast okay very
difficult time for everybody and
government doesn't pretend that it any
anything otherwise I got to keep on
developing those messages and that's why
you're hearing that sort of detail and
before you flee some suggestions that we
should have an extra bank holiday in
October let's be honest we all need one
what do you think well I've heard that
suggestion I don't know how active the
consideration is off of it I think that
I think that by the time we get to
October I think the challenge for us all
would be how to make sure that we can
get back to a position particularly
public services and the economy to get
it as fully active as possible I mean I
I'm all for a bank holidays I'm all for
making sure that we can recharge our
batteries but the challenge might be
somewhat more
one about us getting back to a state of
full activity as quickly as and as
safely as possible okay we could chat
for another half an hour but I know that
would be greedy because lots of other
people want to talk to you so I must let
you go thank you thank you Kay